yeah I can't wait for the day so well
the day is almost here and Prince Harry
is all about preparing for Parenthood
with his pregnant wife Megan Markel
clearly Megan has had certainly a very
positive impact on his life we're in the
homestretch with just weeks to go until
the birth of baby Sussex and a royal
source tells ET that Megan is still
going strong she has told friends that
this is the most exciting the happiest
period in her life
our source adds that on Friday the Duke
and Duchess visited London's
ill apothecary a natural remedies store
near Kensington Palace which is
described on their website as quote in
urban hideaway offering a collection of
healing therapies unique remedies and
workshops to help you create solutions
to issues you may be facing relieve
bodily symptoms and escape from stresses
of urban living according to our source
Perry is focusing all his energy on the
birth of his first child and he's doing
everything he can to put Megan at ease
a new challenge it's a new chapter right
a new chapter in a new home in November
ET learned that the Sussex duo was
planning to trade in their two-bedroom
home at Kensington Palace for the 10
bedroom Frogmore cottage at Windsor
Castle sometime this spring it's a good
hour hour and a half's drive from
Kensington Palace and no this is a very
deliberate move on the Sussex is part
harry's very keen for baby statics to be
brought up in the countryside but he's
also keen to strike out on his own at
the residence holds a special place in
their hearts
it's very close to where Megan and Harry
had their evening reception following
their royal wedding it's also where they
posed for engagement photos they're very
very much looking forward to moving into
their new home in front more cottage
we've learned that the couple is
expected to move any day now good thing
as the Duchess is believed to be due at
the end of April or beginning of May
according to our source Megan's mother
Doria Ragland is expected in London for
the big day in other Sussex news the
Duke and Duchess just got their own
Instagram account at Sussex royal
launched Tuesday morning announcing 1
million followers in just 5 hours and 45
minutes a milestone Guinness World
Records said was reached in record time
and they already have their first post a
slideshow of the couple's travels thus
far which they captioned we look forward
to sharing the work that drives us the
causes we support important
announcements and the opportunity to
shine a light on key issues the new
account appears to be another example of
how Megan and Harry are separating from
William and Kate we're gonna see them
living separate lives once the palace
and their offices at the palace are
separated and I think that's really when
we'll start to see a big difference the
Duke and Duchess of Cambridge will
continue to be featured on at kensington
royal
[Music]